[Musique]
halloween c'est dans quelques jours si
vous cherchez des idées de décoration
encore des idées de déguisements nous
sommes dans une boutique plaisir oise
c'est un parti
[Musique]
pour parler à décoration catherine est à
mes côtés catherine quelles sont les
tendances 2021 pour halloween alors la
grande tendance cette année c'est la
décoration de table puisque on va
pouvoir recevoir être en famille ou
entre amis nous avons de très jolis
gamme que ce soit la gamme citrouille
toute mignonne les classiques exactement
où du de la tête de mort du clown des
choses ensanglanté et plein de petits
sujets de décoration et maintenant on va
partir pour les déguisements avec
plaisir
catherine on va donc passer aux
déguisements vous nous avez fait une
petite sélection chez les filles et chez
les garçons alors chez les filles qu'est
ce qu'on retrouve alors un petit top 3
avec le déguisement d'harley quinn qui
est un énorme succès puisque le film a
super bien fonctionné
un incontournable vampires bien
évidemment et quelque chose d'aussi
d'effroyables avec la
91e chez les garçons alors chez les
garçons bien sûr on ne peut pas parler
dans les queen sans parler du joker il y
a également le personnage sow qui est
très demandé
et toujours le clown ensanglanté qui
fait fureur pour halloween bon je vais
regarder ce qui est ce qui me va le
mieux je vais faire mon choix faites
votre sélection c'est parti
[Musique]
merci catherine ça y est j'ai fait mon
choix ça sera le clown c'est un
excellent choix il vous aller à ravir
vous allez faire frayeur vous pouvez
aussi l'agrémenter avec le masque ou
alors vous faire plaisir avec une paire
de lentilles qui dont l'entrée de gamme
mais à 9 euros 95 les pour un costume
total ça coute combien en moyenne chez
fait sensation alors j'ai fait sensation
on a une gamme de prix très large qui
démarre de vin rouge jusqu'à plus de 80
euros selon les envies et le budget de
chacun merci catherine je passe en
caisse
[Musique]
merci votre chat